The Bachelor is winding down Ben Higgins
and I have been talking all season and I
caught up with him at the taping of
ABC's The Bachelor women tell all
special
we're been revealed he has chosen one
woman he was relieved to say the least
how are you you're really good you told
everybody tonight you're really good
right you keep grilling me over and over
you know I can't say anything you make
my life so difficult you make me hold
all this in and finally tonight it's
time right it's time to like here in a
week to show this woman off to show
realationship off to say that yes when
this was going on I love two women but
now I'm happily in love with one and
that's gonna stay that way for the rest
of my life you are very sure sir and I
like this very sure there's not a
question in my mind it's big news
because Monday night we saw Ben say I
love you to two women both Lauren B and
Jojo on national television that's
borderline breaking a Bachelor rule
that woman that you've chosen have you
addressed the being in love with two
women thing with her what's that
conversation like right away I felt like
it was something that I need to talk
about I knew that I couldn't say goodbye
I was in love with to him but I knew I
couldn't say goodbye to the woman that I
that I was with in the end and so I need
to share with her like my feelings you
know
we're confusing at times but I never
doubted our relationship and it took me
thinking about who I couldn't say
goodbye to for the rest of my life to
really make that decision and it was
hurt what's the ETA well yes I would get
married tomorrow
if that was the right and wise decision
for us to make as a couple I don't think
it is I like I said I want to show her
off I want to date her well when I love
her love on her in public I want people
to see our relationship and see how well
it's going and as we do that maybe take
a little vacation and then start talking
about any place I don't want to push off
a wedding and I think she does
Chris Harrison would marry tomorrow he's
on it he's right maybe maybe there's
more surprises to up somebody's sleeve
The Bachelor women tell all
airs March 7th on ABC